microsoft recently announced that halo
infinite's multiplayer will be free
and i think that's the smartest move
microsoft has made in the last decade
for halo
it's a big shift for the series and one
that could pay dividends to help the
franchise grow
let me explain why the halo franchise is
one of xbox's most valuable assets
but apart from the nostalgia laden halo
the master chief collection the core
franchise has been away from the market
for nearly five years since halo 5 in
2015.
with the series falling out of the
spotlight it's in dire need of a strong
showing from halo infinite to put the
franchise back on the right path
games like call of duty warzone fortnite
and apex legends have set a precedent
that large-scale
highly polished multiplayer games can be
free and microsoft is smart to follow
suit
making halo infinite's multiplayer free
assuming you've got xbox live gold
gives microsoft the best chance to
rekindle the flame and bring halo back
to its former glory
with a free offering this allows the
game to better appeal to lapsed fans
entirely new players and players who
were curious
but never bought in before free to play
halo infinite multiplayer should mean
more players overall
and this is a big deal when we look to
the past one of the issues with halo the
master chief collection at launch was
that it simply did not have enough
players to accommodate the game's
numerous playlists
things got better over time but with
halo infinite's multiplayer being free
out of the gate
the game should have a giant player pool
on launch day that only grows bigger
over time
in theory this will help you find
matches faster and have a better time in
the game
assuming the matchmaking algorithms work
microsoft's latest messaging has been
all about giving people the choice to
play their games however they want
splitting up the paid campaign and
making multiplayer free for halo
infinite is a reflection of this
strategy of freedom of choice
finally if you're only interested in
halo multiplayer you can have it
checking my stats recently i found that
i have more than 1 000 hours logged in
the master chief collection but i've
barely touched the campaigns
i like that i have the option to play
halo's campaigns if i want to
but that option comes at the cost of
buying the game outright
with every xbox and pc user able to play
halo for free
the reach of the game could potentially
grow to an unprecedented level of scale
for the series and make it a serious
money maker
microtransactions from the free-to-play
call of duty war zone are estimated to
bring in hundreds of millions of dollars
every quarter
even if infinite only makes a portion of
that and it would likely be smaller
considering it's a platform exclusive
that would still be a very large chunk
of change now
you and i don't need to care about the
profitability of halo infinite's
multiplayer
that's for the bean counters at
microsoft to be concerned about but
looking into the business model can be a
constructive way of examining wider
trends and strategies that microsoft may
employ
for the game it's fair to be skeptical
about how halo infinite will implement
its microtransactions after all
there are many egregious examples of
microtransactions in this industry
1343 finally does reveal halo infinite's
multiplayer i hope the studio lays
its cards on the table early or they run
the risk of people assuming the worst
another way that free to play could help
halo infinite is that it helps ensure
the player base stays connected over the
years
we've heard that halo infinite will be a
platform that's supported for 10 years
and it's exciting as a halo fan to think
about where the game could go
over time without having to worry about
buying a sequel every few years
i can envision a future where halo
infinite adds new map packs cosmetics
and lots more over time and players can
invest in whatever they like
that said as fortnite apex legends and
warzone experienced before it halo
infinite's multiplayer going free could
enable problems related to cheating and
other offenses
343 will need to make assurances to the
player base that it is taking cheating
seriously
all in all microsoft has shown precisely
zero multiplayer footage for halo
infinite so it's too soon to get
properly excited
with the lackluster reveal for the
campaign mode in july fans are right to
be skeptical but i'm hoping these fears
are unfounded
343 has promised to show halo infinite's
multiplayer soon
and talk about its many innovations and
i can't wait to see it with the halo
franchise falling out of favor recently
making infinite's multiplayer free could
be the beginning of a new era for halo
[Music]
you